welcome to our first mac site expert
interview my name is leslie ashinger and
i am the strategic director of marketing
applications at macsite i will be your
host for today's interview style q a
session with a familiar guest of ours
our event today is a follow-up event
from a webinar we conducted earlier this
year in q2
during that webinar matias boza a post
doctoral researcher and technology
manager at vkf dead heidelberg describe
the development of nanosmart vectors
designed to provide stable expression
while causing minimal disruptions to
t-cell activity as a result of that
webinar event many of you viewers had
some additional questions for matthias
about
combining the gmp compliant maxi flow
electroporation system with the melting
clinimex prodigy automated cell
processing platform
we think you will find today's session
very engaging and at the conclusion you
will learn how nsmart vectors are used
to optimize adaptive cell therapies and
really understand the value of coupling
these two powerful technologies to
create a gmp-compatible large-scale car
t manufacturing with nsmar vectors
matthias are you ready to kick off the
session
absolutely thank you very much for
inviting me lately
absolutely our pleasure to have you back
again and why don't we go ahead and get
started
sure so
can you give us a brief overview of your
end smart vectors and how they are being
used to optimize adaptive cell therapies
sure so the n-smart vector is a dna
vector platform that we developed at the
german cancer research center in in
heidelberg it is based on an antibiotic
select antibiotic-free selection that
was the that was developed at nature
technology corporation a company that is
based in nebraska us and that combined
the the advantages of having an
antibiotic free selection system
together with the
skateboard matrix attachment regions
that we have developed in in heidelberg
in the last
during the last 10 years so by combining
these two technologies we generated a
vector that is a dna
factor that is a non-viral which is
mostly based on mammalian dna
i would say almost entirely based in
human dna
that can be very efficiently produced in
in bacteria that can produce in bacteria
without the need of post processing
once
it can be produced as a normal as a
normal overprep
and that can and that once that is
introduced into into human cells it can
be maintained and it can be replicated
from the human cells without the need of
accessory viral protein
so what we
we as i mentioned we developed this in
the last decade almost here here in in
hardback and only recently in the last
couple of years we decided to leverage
this technology for the production of
adult dissel 30 products with a with a
particular focus for for car t cells
production
and as part of the webinar i was was
describing how we um how we use these
these tags to to make uh to make parties
in your publication from science
advances earlier this year you mentioned
you wanted to determine if end-smart
vectors would be suitable for clinical
applications in engineering primary t
cells
and as a result you tested the large
scale electrician of end smart vectors
and human cd3 positive cells using both
the max site expert gt platform as well
as another electro creation platform
so that being said
why did you decide to choose using mac
site over the alternative ep device
so the whole idea of the of of using
non-viral system is to is to shorten the
time necessary for producing these these
products
so you know as a as everyone is aware of
when we use viral systems it takes about
an average 20 25 days and is a rather
complex supply chain so what we wanted
to do was to really shorten these vein
to in time using fresh products by using
also in-house gmp facility
and the so our decision to use the max
set was really um dictated by the fact
that by having such a compressed
protocol we really were looking for high
viability post-electroporation
and the expert device was the with a
large electropressure less operation
devices that gave us the highest
viability post post ep
and when i say pause i'm i'm referring
to 24 24 hours after that preparation
perfect so then you're you my next
question i think you just answered was
the recovery time from the cells did
that factor into your decision on what
technology to use going forward it
sounds like it did
yes absolutely absolutely so the whole
idea is that we we don't want to you
know by
by having low viability we don't want to
basically to waste a lot of the material
coming from the patient it's very
precious material and some of the
patients even liquor phrases are even
from glucopharyna we cannot extrapolate
a lot of cells
so we really have to care
about the cell's viability and fitness
after ep and this was for for me the the
most crucial
parameter
in the manufacturing workflow you have
established at dkf's ed combining the
gmp compliant maxi flow electroporation
system and the clinimax prodigy
automated cell processing system
what final volume have you been able to
achieve using this workflow and how many
patients can you treat as a result
yeah so for the dna manufacturing we can
produce
up to thousands of patients we produce
roughly two and a half gram per liter
which isn't from an off-the-shelf
product
it lasts for for roughly thousands of
patients however we are also tailoring
this process for individualized
medicines where we want to produce one
tcr or
more up to
whatever 10 dcrs in a virtual time
window and that's something we
also managed to achieve regarding the
the manufacturing so we were um
we can produce with such with such
protocol about uh we can manufacture in
two products sorry
for um for four products per month
considering that every product takes
about seven days and when we compare
these two legible-produced products is
significantly
significantly better because the the
manufacturing protocol with with an
antivirus takes about 15 days which
clearly which will improve the
turnaround
the turnaround of the patient and the
number of patients that we can treat
with with the doctor's cell therapy
okay can you comment on mac site's
reproducibility when transfecting and
smart vectors into primary cells and
what implications this has for cgmp
i think that the device is very robust i
think we we do see
variability which which is donor
dependence which is expected to be
elective
however when we introduce for example a
car we can
consistently hit more than sixty percent
of the cells
and when we introduce the tcr uh it is
slightly better and we can hit the
robustly over eighty percent of the
cells
um and this goes from eighty to 90 90
99.9 that really depends from from the
donor
okay
in the 2021 webinar you delivered back
in june you discussed the minimal
effects of the n-smart vectors that the
hat on on t-cell gene expression so why
is it important for the functionality of
your vectors in the development of car t
cells
well we we compared what are the overall
perturbations of cells that were
infected with the lentivirus or the
cells that were electroporated with with
the expert device and what we found is
that
the the introduction of the dna by
electroporation has a minimal impact on
the cell's homeostasis
while when we introduced the the the
gene the gene of interest by by
antivirus we saw a
larger number of genes that were either
up or down regulated
which actually made us speculating that
you know
it's kind of that the cells recognize
that are infected by a virus and they
are somewhat fighting the infection
indeed we found marker of this uh these
uh fight up regulated
while when we do this by lack operation
we don't see um such such effect
and uh
you know and i have to say that when we
when we just look at the um you know no
dna control when we just deliver the the
pulse
we we really find we we couldn't really
find any gene that are
massively up or down regulated now
regulated actually i don't think we can
find i think we there are less less than
a dozen genes that really change which
made us concluding that the
electroporation has literally no impact
on on those cells
while the the effects that we see are
really really triggered either by the
dna which are very minimal or by the
virus that are more significant
right
and then similarly along that same vein
did electroporation of the cells impact
the ratio of the cd4 positive in cd8
positive cells in the populations or
cell proliferation
no
you know cells that have been elected
that were where we delivered the dna or
that we follow up um all
only um
also with no dna um so that the
proliferation were was was not affected
at all and as well as the the the racist
d3 uh sorry cd4 cd8 was not affected by
by the last operation
so i can generally i would say that the
lx operation
has
literally no impact on those cells
nor the homeostasis nor the the
phenotype of the cells i mean the the
the the changes that we will see in the
population are
are induced by the culturing so the way
we decide to culture the cells
but the the ep itself is basically
harmless
okay
your team demonstrated that
electroporation of the n-smart plasmid
resulted in a t cell with more naive
state relative to lentiviral infections
do you believe this would impact t cell
exhaustion and the efficacy of the car t
cell therapy
yes so
this comes down to what we we mentioned
before right if we deliver by ep
and we use a basically an invisible
vector
the cells do not feel that they have
been modified so they
they do not feel that something foreign
has been introduced
while if we do the same procedure with
the lentivirus the cells start to feel
the infection start to fight the
infection and as a result if a cell is
busy fighting an infection is not as
good
um concentrate in killing a tumor right
while if we have a cell that is
basically in this naive state state that
has been modified with a very gentle um
technology or a platform then it's
probably
more efficient in killing the tumor
cells and that's really what we saw in
the results in in our in our in our
hands that cells that have been modified
with the plasma with an end smart plus
electroporation are much more efficient
in recognizing and killing the tumor
cells compared to cells that were made
with the virus
okay great
um in your opinion will max science
electroporation approach help with
therapeutic applications of the card t
cells in this regard
yeah i think absolutely i think that the
fact that we can you know
work at scale um
really from from small to extra-large
scale
which such
efficacy of delivery and such high
viability will certainly help
the transition into into clinical
applications
and did you experience any technical
challenges when pairing the miltoni
clinic max prodigy system with the
maxsite gt expert electroporation system
yeah i think
it really depends from from
at which scale we want to work at
i think if we
um
at extra large scale you know at slr
scale is not a big is it a bit difficult
it's not
very difficult because the miltoni
formulate the cells
at 100 mils and 100 meals is also the
upper limit to the the
the biggest uh max size cassettes so the
cl2
which will not make any any problem the
problem could be uh
you know that that that you may need to
adjust the size concentration
but in terms of volumes there's no
there's not
there's no much problem
however when we want to work in smaller
scales you know when you want to work
with a
cl1 or um
or with other quests or other pas
um then there is a problem because then
the the the miltoni can only formulate
at 100 wheels and then you have to you
have to centrifuge and adjust your cell
uh your cell concentration which clearly
makes the problem
that we have to open the system so then
the system is not closed anymore and
uh we need to be creative to find a way
to make it you know gmp compatible
yeah and since you're already on that
topic what approach did you take to
enhance the pairing of the two systems
to
act as almost you know a semi-closed
system in that particular
example you just gave
we
so we we concentrate the cells using uh
um
you can you can concentrate the cells
using
concentrators in bags such as the rotia
provided by by sema fisher and this is
it is a closed system so you can visit
the
wealth uh bags and concentrate
um
i think going going forward i think that
um
if if uh whenever a mac site um whenever
maxes will release bags with smaller
capacity would make things probably um
easier to to couple the two couple of
two technologies in our case um
we uh we
often had to centrifuge and basically
open the system so we are not really
entirely entirely close so we are we're
working on a solution to to keep the
system closed
that process you just described it was
that labor intensive to produce the car
t cells with the two platforms combined
no no no
it was not labor intensive i think every
every experience you know
technician or ever experienced gmp
technician can can make there it can
make it it's particularly simple
actually because the miltoni it's a
rather straightforward
instrument that does the uh that does
everything that's the isolation of the
t-cells from uh from a leukophresis
that's very straightforward and as well
as the the expert is
is very straightforward when it comes to
electroporation so
the only the only really
tricky point is when you have to adjust
your cell concentration depending on
which scale you want to work at that's
really the only moment where you may
have to open the system or uh or have
very fine-tuned your your condition with
a hundred meals
okay are there any
any other areas for further optimization
for your workflow for the car t cell
production
i think we need to i think we really
need to to determine what are the what
are the um working range
um
for example you know
the the
it's uh it's not very it's still not
very
very
robust the number of cells for example
that you can activate the with the with
the melting in such in a very short
period of time you know we're talking
about seven days of protocol which means
that we use three days of activation
and uh um
sometimes the you know it's already
variable the number of cells that you
that you can generate after three days
of activation it's not a huge range but
it's still is still a range
and then from there we need to
then optimize actually define what are
the working concentration ranges in the
intellect operations in the next
operations as well
and clearly if we if we want to even
shorten the protocol this has to be done
for every every step for every
activation day that we we decided to to
to trim
so there so if the idea is clearly to
have it the the shortest possible if
possible with no non-activation no
activation at all and that clearly
requires
some fine tuning of the
of the cell number cell volumes and dna
concentration for the for the
electroporation
okay and in your opinion did maxite
contribute to the decrease in time
required to get your car t cells into
the clinic
i think so generally absolutely i think
as we said you know by having
a device that can really generate cells
with high viability and high efficacy
at the end of the day
it's a matter of how many cells you can
produce in a given time window
and
if we if if the idea is to make these
cells
in the shortest time windows possible
then a device that allows you to make
you know very viable
and uh um
a lot of positive cells it's clearly
helping us in in shaving shaving time to
this to this protocol
great
and just a few additional questions uh
what makes the nsmart vector unique or
novel
well it is the only vector that only dna
or plasmid dna
based vector that is able to
auto-replicate when it's in cells so
basically there's no other technologies
based on dna and plasma dna
that
do not exploit viral protein that are
able to be
cell
to be replicated into from human cells
without either killing the cells or
integrating into the cell so this is the
only platform that once is delivered in
cells can be replicated and maintained
without being integrated
and have you tried to transfect multiple
nsmar vectors in a single
electroporation and is multiplexing
possible with your technology
yes that's where we are that's where we
are leading to i think
multiple transactions is uh um
is one thing however by having a
non-viral systems you know you make you
may want to combine everything in one
because you know the payload
size is not a limitation um we are
trying we multiplexing for example for
delivering of several tcrs however we
are not really multiplexing in the same
transfection we are multiplexing in you
know several electro operations
but uh um sure i mean deliberative or
delivery of multiple of multiple vectors
is something we we have we work on and
and
and and it's feasible it's uh and it
works very well
right
are you using the n-smart vectors in
other application areas or with other
cell types
yes we are trying we are trying to
exploit every cell types so to say we
are using uh you know the word
the natural application was cartes
trendy um clearly we are now working on
nks
uh but we have uh we have applied the
vector to modify must embryonic muscle
brain stem cells or human or human stem
cell
so we are exploiting the possibility of
doing regenerative medicine too
and we are going back a little bit to
the principle of
um all gene therapy you know in vivo
gene delivery and
and in vivo gene therapy
and just as a last question what are
your next plan and future studies do you
have plans to move into the clinic
yes
so we are we really hope to get next
year into the clinic we are
um we are
trying to acquire funding for a um
noble tcr approach you know to see our
base
for a phase one two combined
and uh um being in in this situation
where we have a very close relation with
the national cancer national
tumor center in hardenberg we were
involved in
compassionate use trials too
so i think next year will be really the
year where
we will apply inpatient for the first
time cells made with such platform
great well that's all the questions we
have that i have for you matthias uh so
thank you very much and i wanted to just
say um again thank you for all of your
efforts and providing our viewers with
your detailed answer i wanted to thank
our event sponsors lab roots for all of
your assistance organizing this
informative session and wanted to thank
our audience participants for your
continued engagement and for providing
great follow-up questions from our
original webinar event
this concludes our session for today and
we look forward to future events so
thank you again very much matthias
thank you thank you